you
ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
stand back and stand by
[Music]
let's please continue on person woman
[Music]
that's amazing how did you do that
that's amazing
i do it because i have like a good
memory because i'm
cognitively there
[Music]
what is oh on here we won't talk about
toilets
it's a very unpleasant story you know
they call them dumps big massive dumps
if my grandmother had wheels instead of
legs
oranges oranges she would be a bicycle
god bless the united states thank you
very much
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
the france
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we are
standing by
for oh where are my graphics my graphics
hold on a second here oh there they are
okay good
we are standing by for white house press
secretary
jan saki who will be delivering a press
briefing
really really soon and we i it's so
great to have some time with you guys
because there are so many things going
on
and to talk about watching that
introductory video and seeing
last year's garden and seeing questions
i do have a 2021
uh garden and there are no
cukes or zooks i will not be exposing
my zooks or cukes this year because i
have none
but i have a 2021 garden and i don't
know maybe i'll
would i do a tour video i guess i would
yeah
um maybe if we get if we get to 100
website members
i will film a garden tour here's what i
have in my 2021 garden
i have yellow and red tomatoes
well no let me go backwards first of all
as far as
perennial elements that just come back
on their own
my strawberry plant has come back
really strongly it is last year i got
six strawberries and as you remember i
like ate one with a single mint leaf and
made a whole video out of it but um the
strawberry plant i expect it to go
crazy this year two types of oregano are
back
and my time my time is already bigger
than you know bob ross's hair
i've already had to trim it so really
really strong and then mint i have an
entire mint pot and it is going bananas
already okay so that's that
new plantings japanese eggplant i'm
going to try to grow
i got green peas and they're already
they're throwing
shoots out and i've already given them a
trellis
i have two um tomato types
an heirloom yellow grape tomato it's
like the mo
i wanted the most pretentious possible
tomato
and an heirloom grape yellow tomato was
basically it
um and i said to the the tomatoes sir
this is where you will be growing so
i've got yellow and red tomatoes
um some various lettuce things i got
romaine i have four romaine plants
and i have some uh i guess it's
it's they called it gourmet lettuces and
i was like that sounds completely
delusionally pretentious so i'm gonna
get that a three types of peppers i've
got a sweet banana pepper
a jalapeno and a
um what was the third kind like a mini
red
bell pepper oh
for basil you know everybody's always
doing
italian basil it's just like you just
start dumping basil everywhere and it's
you know you get it and it's green and
everybody knows italian basil i instead
have decided this year to do purple
basil
it's basically italian basil just purple
and a little bit less fragrant
it's the same thing it just looks cool
purple basil and
i got thai basil for some of my um
uh asian recipes which is fantastic
and then i think that's mostly oh i got
cilantro
i'm also propagating it so i'm trying to
get a very thick
cilantro bush essentially um
and then what else i i really think that
that's it i mean that's a lot of stuff
already
um yeah but
massive basal dumps different types of
basil so that's all going on okay
if we get to 100 members i will do a a
garden tour
and we are already at uh phoenix ashes
has gifted five
chief boris signed up emeronic signed up
is seven megawatt is eight
monsion his nine kimioyo is ten
so we're already at ten so that may
happen
that may happen oh and sorry on
jointpakman.com
eric wigand has signed up and is number
eleven so we may actually get that
garden tour coming up really soon
okay i'm going to jump right into
substance because i have so much of it
hella cool guy says first donation means
i'm the best
jacob says first record of the stream
best introduction in history and alex
kepcke asks if i have a charcoal or a
gas grill i have gas
right now um just you know if i want to
quickly grill on a weeknight
i don't want to spend 45 minutes getting
my coals stoked
right um so i'm i'm going gas
right now all right we have a a
horrible oh by the way new meme format
this is really good this appeared on the
the subreddit yesterday
um sometimes i'll open a story by saying
just as we've been predicting for weeks
and this is me giving myself an award
for uh when i make an obvious prediction
on the show
and so this is good i am opening this to
whoever wants to participate
send in your images just change the text
at the top this is widely available
on our subreddit but this is really good
what's funny is when i look at this
these are so not my hands
like you know i have no wedding ring and
it just nothing about this hand look
it's like an alien hand it's like when
you wake up at night
and you have a pinched nerve and you've
lost feeling in your arm and it
feels like someone else's arm that is
what i see when i look at this
oh are those obama's hands that makes it
even funnier yeah
this maybe this is from obama that
actually makes it hilarious
then those definitely are not my hands
obviously okay so this is available on
the subreddit and you can um
you can take advantage of that okay look
we need people to get vaccinated right
now
we are on the precipice of hopefully
going down to
almost zero from the standpoint of cases
look at what happened when israel
vaccinated people
look at that look at that 70 cases
look at what happened when the
population got vaccinated so
we need to do it but vaccinations are
declining
as you can see vaccinations peaked on
average
almost three weeks ago and then since
they've just been
declining why is this happening well the
people that really wanted the vaccine
increasingly have gotten it or at least
their first dose
we now are dealing with anti-vaxxers and
sadly
tucker carlson is continuing to spread
anti-vaxx propaganda
this is from last night let's take a
look not mean that they are dangerous
and we are not claiming the chronos
virus vaccines are dangerous
but we are telling the truth so this is
already pretty sophisticated propaganda
right
he starts with we're not saying they are
dangerous
but and then in the back it says
mandatory vaccinations which there are
none
there's no mandatory vaccinations so
it's
already sort of sophisticated propaganda
i mean listen he's
saying that he's not saying that the
vaccines are bad
okay here we go which is there are
unresolved concerns about their
long-term effects on some
people including their effects on female
fertility
that is not a conspiracy theory that is
true
it's an honest question what's the
long-term effect that no one so far has
been able to answer
now remember with this long-term effect
stuff
you can always say
what if the effects show up just
outside of the time period that
something has been tested
let me give you an example uh the polio
vaccine has been around i don't know how
long it's but let's call it 70 years i
don't know 60 years
you could always say we don't yet know
the effects of the polio vaccine
starting after 61 years we just don't
know i'm not
saying anything bad happens we just do
not know
at year 61 what does the polio vaccine
do you can
always say that it's not a resolvable
issue
um and and but here now he's going to
make some specific claims about the
fertility thing and it's not even really
about fertility but pay close attention
and it's not simply being asked by
partisans it's being asked by practicing
physicians
catherine lee for example is a research
fellow in the division of public health
sciences
at washington university in st louis lee
doesn't seem like a partisan republican
or a q a on adherent or a crank she
gladly took the chronovirus vaccine she
seems to support the chronovirus vaccine
strongly
but then in herself she noticed
unexpected effects on her menstrual
cycle
quote it wasn't a symptom that was on
the list lee said
i expected that my arm would be sore or
that i might have a fever or headache
but this just wasn't on the list kate
clancy
another scientist who studies female
fertility at the university of illinois
okay so let's stop it this quote from
katherine lee
is an accurate quote um
and there have been reports of
heavy or irregular menstrual cycles in
the immediate aftermath of code of
covert vaccines they're anecdotal
but when you talk about stressing the
immune system which is what a vaccine is
supposed to do
uh female menstrual cycle cycles are
very sensitive to that
he's talking about fertility even though
he's quoting someone
about menstrual cycle uh changes
and what he's not telling you is if you
go to the full quote by katherine lee
there's an article in the verge
find the quote she says
none of this would affect fertility
there's no belief there's no assertion
that any of this would affect fertility
so it's a partial quote fertility and
straight menstruation are two different
things so i'm not going to go through
the full thing here but this is just to
give you a sense of how deceptive this
stuff is and then when you go to the end
by the way
then something that says no question no
questions allowed pops up which is like
who's not being allowed to ask questions
for the vaccines
never tested for the effects on the
female menstrual cycle or for fertility
or on pregnant women
by the way i'd be shocked if there's any
pre-menopausal women
even in tucker carlson's audience that's
a different question but that's more of
a demographic issue
so maybe the symptoms amount to nothing
that's often the case
maybe they amount to something we don't
know
the fact is we can't say what the
long-term effects of this vaccine will
be
on women including pregnant women honest
people
admit this every scientist knows it so
again you know
we can't say well a lot of these issues
have been studied mrna has been studied
adenovirus vaccines have been studied
that we we actually do but then they
they just go back to
we just can't say we also can't say what
is the effect of the vaccine
long term i'm talking you know after 10
years on a tennis backhand
we just don't know the vaccine may be
perfectly safe and fine for a tennis
backhand
it may not we just don't know because
it's not been 10 years what is the
10-year effect on tennis backhands
and then the no questions allowed up who
the questions are all being asked
they've mostly all been answered as
well so anyway the problem is that
this is the problem right that
vaccination is declining
and this is not the time when we want
vaccination to uh
to be declining so that's that that's
the latest from
tucker carlson okay
uh i do want to say thank you to khan
kriha who has signed up on my website
joinpackman.com i also want to say thank
you to
weatherboxer who just gifted five subs
on twitch um
extremely exciting also huge thank you
to snuggles odw and trish the dish for
their continued support
via via twitch as well we're standing by
for gen saki
but so many things to talk about between
now and then
a few super chats okay um
frompis says largest south american
ashkenazi jewish youtube stream on may
4th
2021 historic moment breaking multiple
records
that's right if you are in the audience
right now
and i hope people are prepared for the
with great power comes great
responsibility
you are watching right now the biggest
may 4th 2021 stream
hosted by a left-handed
argentinian jew with american
citizenship
in that category this is the
most watched live stream of the day
in news and politics on youtube
all right that is really an
accomplishment that
somebody should get an award for peter
wants to know what is the girth of my
biceps i don't know i've never measured
them i know my head size
is like off the charts five head is not
a metaphor when it comes to me it is uh
it is it is a a certainty
kyle says david what are your thoughts
on bitcoin emissions
um they can be zero in the sense that
electricity can be generated renewably
so i don't have any particular thoughts
on that that are unique no coverage of
recent israeli apartheid crimes
come on guys come on invest in humans
david we are long-term
fans from new york germany we have
launched a crowd fund to build an
app to solve climate change would
appreciate a shout out go
fund me invest in humans okay not an
endorsement but
if people are interested i i don't know
anything about it but certainly people
can
investigate that and that would be a
delightful thing to do
do oh do i have any twitch
unban requests let's see
oh i do i do okay hold on
here is my gavel we do have an unban
request
a user whistling tomb
showed up here on a recent live stream
their first message was all caps f biden
trump 2024 they apparently did not get
the reaction they wanted
so then they said trump 2024
also in all caps they were then banned
which was the right decision
and their unban request is can i ask why
so this to me feels more like a timeout
ban trump 2020 it's like
that's that seems more troll trump 2024
okay maybe you want trump maybe trump
2024 i'm actually okay
with an unban on this one and i will
adjudicate that right
now but we're going to keep a very close
eye on them i think it was the right
decision
as a temporary timeout but you know if
they want to come back and participate
meaningfully
then i'm willing to allow them back in
that is the only unban
request i have um
oh okay i have a bunch of different
voicemails to play
and let's see where to even start so i
have
um i have a bunch of different
things so let me get this first one out
of the way
i know that we have a system now where
we go to the audience about whether to
play troy york voicemails and it's
actually been over a month
where i've not even gone to the audience
because the troy york voicemails are so
boring and just ridiculous and i don't
even want to
uh subject you to that but i haven't i'm
making an executive decision
i got a troy york voicemail and he
sounds completely wasted he's this was
left at like 3am
he has never sounded this drunk so
merely for medical value this is a
warning to any children do not you know
alcoholism is a serious issue and we're
not ridiculing that
this is the worst troy york has ever
sounded it's really short we're just
going to take a quick listen
this is back oh yeah i'm calling david
pakman
uh are you referring to your video about
the world
he's referring referring to my video
uh says that uh trump
now that trump is gone the usa is
popular again
and uh yeah i think the world uh
likes not having trump because then they
can take advantage
advantage of america again
yeah so it is sad and he's just
absolutely wasted so we're going to move
off of that but that's just
i'm just letting you guys know the troy
york stuff is continuing even though
he's been off air for five weeks
okay i want to say thank you to dirt
knapp beaver smart
napa skip dog
um for the twitch subs numbers 14
15 and 16. this is also a perfect day
to grab a membership on my website
joinpakman.com as i
promised if we get this bar to 100 i
will
go out and film the 2021
um garden tour which is
an incredible tour an incredible tour
okay next many of you have been asking
what happened to the guy that would call
in and refer to me as
prickles he has been m.i.a for a really
long time
he has called in let's listen to oh so
let me delete these as i go troy york
wasted we've done
here is prickless guy by popular demand
hey trickless it's me uh people in glass
houses shouldn't throw bricks
at least trump could get up the steps of
an airplane
uh he doesn't even fall down three times
and at least he knows where he is
yeah trump could get up he couldn't get
down a ramp though
your boy lion biden the the hemorrhoid
doesn't even know where he is he said oh
i'm in primark
he's in new hampshire but why doesn't he
why isn't he able to go up and down the
steps of a plane without falling
three times you're an idiot so is he
and then stays on for a while unable to
hang up the phone
all right and eventually was able to
hang up the phone so that's by popular
demand that's prickly sky
uh we do have a new sponsor they are
pretty aggressive undies
and they are called sheaths and
um clearly talking about sheaths has
raised questions about swords to
continue the kind of double entendres
but here's a voicemail caller weighing
in i guess about
underpants hi david
david um i've heard that you're gonna
have a really good show today
so i'm looking forward to uh to that
show
um i saw that you have new
advertisements for
underpants now um they prevent your
crotch from getting too
sweaty or or chafing or anything like
that
hey listen uh he's understanding the
product that's great
so i'm hoping to see during your show
kind of similar to the
wine commercial where you're just
looking at a different thing or the the
steady stratford shirts commercial where
you're looking at like woman bottles
you're like reading a book
doing various things i'm hoping to see
that but with you wearing those
underpants
right not sure if they're gonna fit for
me so to see that bottle
to see if can i read a book wearing them
can i can i look at a wine label i'm
just not sure about that
yep no there i will give you a full
rundown of everything that can be done
with the sheath
uh boxers for sure it's a and it's an
extensive list
um okay so we've got that you know this
funny thing has actually been happening
with the advertisements where
the advertisements are they've become
almost like part of the entertainment of
the show where it's like
what brand are we advertising today and
what ridiculous b-roll do we have of me
you know pouring a drink or reading a
book or what people
people write to me not a lot but i do
like two to three percent of the emails
we get
are people reacting to the hilarity of
the ads which i think is funny i think
i think that's a great thing okay we
heard
from the eggman
and the eggman i don't know if you guys
remember last week
there was a call where someone called in
from belgium and i asked them about
their favorite sauces for fries
and the egg man i guess i had asked that
same caller the same question like a
year ago i had no memory of it i admit
it
and the egg man said he didn't even mind
hearing it a second time listen to this
this is really funny
hi dave look i'm not like that other
caller that gets upset
when you ask the guy from amsterdam
antwerp
what kind of french fry sauce he likes
on his french fries
um multiple times because we all
remember he liked the same sauce last
time that he called i don't know
yeah i have no memory of that that's i
mean it sounds like something i would
ask but it's funny i have absolutely no
memory that i had
the exact conversation with the same
belgian caller bother me
i like the questions but dave when a
young american caller calls you and you
hear background noise and he says this
is mom's tv
how can you not ask what is your mom
watching on tv
that's fair the eggman is actually a
really good producer
um it it it would have been a great
and obvious question to say what is your
mom watching in the background i just
missed it
i admit i missed it the opportunity like
that's the most obvious question in the
world more obvious a question to your
american listeners than what kind of
soft dude puts on his french fries which
still is interesting by the way i'm not
putting that down so um i just wanted to
know what that kid's mom was watching on
tv was it like judge judy or
you know csi or you know fox news
it would have interested me greatly to
hear that shalom brother
all right shalom to the eggman and uh he
make he's making good points i certainly
could not um
could not argue with anything that he
says there
i want to say a big thank you to barbara
degalado who has just signed up at
joinpackman.com
i also want to say thank you to chris
mclafferty
for the website sign up those are new
members 17 and
18 and then over on twitch
gerlaxel jar laxi
has signed up via twitch and is new
member number 19.
very much appreciate that okay
and then the last thing i have
for you from voicemails is
uh oh sorry hold on a second
we've got to ban someone here
um block there it is sorry just dropping
some ban hammers apologize
okay last voicemail thing let's just
keep an eye on what's going on here okay
still still standing by for gensake
here's a new anti-vaxx caller
new anti-vaxx caller okay they left a
series of voicemails
and this is really concerning it's
concerning
because of this which we were talking
about before
reduced vaccine doses fewer and fewer
people getting vaccinated
merely because they don't want to
vaccines are available okay
new anti-vax caller listen to this yeah
david uh it's eric from mass again
uh it seems like either you have the
inability
or that i want to go get the real
information
information go to no jab
for me dot info that's no okay
hold on the website is no jab for me
dot info okay it's an insane
website it's an insane website
uh it's just anti-vaxx trash
um they do this thing where vaccines is
in quotation marks it's a crazy website
so he wants me to look at this website
no jab
for me let's continue good job for me
that info get yourself some real
information and read
i'm lacking information that says there
and maybe you're going to stop your
little videos
that are right yeah this website will
make it so i never do vaccine videos
again
mm-hmm that's an idea
yeah david sorry
and read what that says there and maybe
you're going to stop your little videos
that are misleading and
telling people to do something they
shouldn't be doing
i suggest you check that website um it
has a lot of information that has the
real information
and i think your viewers would be very
interested in it and uh
i'm interested to see if you put it up
on your uh
little videos because um well i did yeah
and i don't know that
uh no jab for me dot info
is going to be interesting to anybody in
my audience hey david it's eric again
from mass um i just wanted to elaborate
a little
on uh no jab for me dot info
and just say it's gonna be kind of be
hard for you
to go against it because um
you're on your little videos saying uh
believe
all doctors and i i don't know that i've
ever
used that phrase on my show believe all
doctors is not a phrase i've i've used
no jab for me dot info was done by all
doctors i actually got i don't know
anything about that website
i got a really funny let me see if i can
find this hold on
uh would it be under general audience
emails or is it under hate mail i don't
know
vaccine doctor let me see here
there was a really funny one i got
uh i don't so i got the i got an email
from someone saying you know david you
should really be listening to what
medical doctors are saying about
vaccines
here is a link to such a website and i
click onto it and it's an
anti-vaxx website and it is written by a
guy who is named
doctor something but when you look uh
he's like a doctor of like american
literature
so i wrote back to the woman and i said
i agree
with you we should be listening to the
medical doctors the website you sent to
me
you sent me is writ is is it's a guy
who's an expert in
in literature i mean he has a phd but
it's not a medical doctor
and then she just wrote back with
something totally different about fauci
this or fouchy that
there's no talking sense with these
people
here's a little more of this believe all
doctors
you've said it ad nauseum
i mean listen if we're gonna just
believe all doctors i'll listen to jill
biden about
vaccines you know one more yeah sarah
from mass
um call it again because i don't
understand why you would not put a
no jab for me got info
uh on your site to let you we we put it
up i can look at what's happening in the
chat people are not impressed
listeners know the dangers of the
experimental
treatment it's not a vaccine and it's
not fda approved your
boy fauci is lying you can look that up
doctors say that and you said trust all
doctors
and you also said um yeah i'm gonna have
a social
uh psychologist on i really think you
should because you're so deep in lies
you need one
i don't you know so they don't even seem
to know what a social psychologist is so
wow that's that's really sad so
education is in a deep deep crisis in
the united states so that's that that's
voicemails for today
um that's basically
basically the you know just that's what
that's what it is all right
uh big thank you to drew english drew
english
just grabbed a website membership at
we do have an unpublished secret
but extremely exciting coupon code that
code is immoral 21.
you can use that code to get a discount
so
big it's not moral
uh based on judeo-christian philosophy
of course
uh immoral 21. i also want to say thank
you to ozzy
v megan solo
kalestines
pilot dog for signing up via twitch
putting us at 25 thanks guys i
appreciate that
let's do some super chats i've fallen
very far behind
stephen b says troy york needs a 72-hour
cycle
i'm worried septic avenger
says are you concerned in the future the
u.s might end up in a situation
similar to argentina because of our ever
increasing spending and debt
no that that you would only come to that
conclusion
um with what at this point i think is a
um a not very accurate understanding of
debt and deficit
for-profit says why is israeli apartheid
funny
i have dozens of clips about the
israeli-palestinian conflict on my
youtube channel you can find my thoughts
there
ryan says biden said he would pull
troops from afghanistan do you believe
he would be as likely to do regime
change in other countries like obama and
bush did
no and by the way speaking of that
more and more people seem including the
revolutionary
left seem to be convinced
that joe biden is going to war with
china or russia
i think there is almost no chance in
hell
that joe biden goes to war with china
nor russia
i just don't what i no if you gave me
even odds i would i would vote no on
that very
very easily and clearly um
ice wallow says chat chill out david
does u.s politics not israel
and then another user says human rights
watch declared apartheid
so people arguing with each other about
israel
astyrian says about 10 days after my
first modernist shot i decimated a tough
team in my league tennis match i'd argue
they snuck
in performance-enhancing microchips that
seems plausible
absolutely susk says
recent to stephen michael davis video on
you please
i don't know what that means stephen
michael
davis david pakman what is that
let's see february
david pakman ratioed by delusional
progressives
i don't know what this is about
this is also pretty old
all right i'll i'll bite let's hope
these are not famous last week i'm
worried
about a faction of my audience and and
quite frankly i'm really worried about
the left and this is not
concern trolling i'm worried because of
the response to a video that i did
yesterday explaining some unfortunate
realities
about medicare for all a while back
professional gamer ninja tweeted
i'll never understand how college and
nfl football teams allow kickers that
just
miss kicks i feel like there has to be
pools of kickers in the usa that won't
miss simple kicks
or snappers that won't mess the snaps i
don't know man it seems so silly would
love opinions on this
i'm not a gamer but this was not the
first i had heard of ninja
wow this is a 20 minute video so this is
let's see if there's any part that's
actually about me
i don't think my audience cares about a
lot of this stuff
uh let's see scrolling through here
yeah i don't know oh here's more about
me let's see right after me maybe
there's like a commentary here
we'll make it not happen politically how
did his audience take this
well the ratio on the video is pretty
brutal 2.1 k likes to 1.8k dislikes
highly unusual for a popular channel
like david's also
after this video a number of people in
the progressive sphere predictably
denounced him as a sellout to bring this
video back to the beginning this is a
consequence of thinking things are easy
when they're not
most online progressives have bought the
premise that politics is completely
simple
politics is an easy game that we make
difficult
all those overpaid democratic
strategists in washington dc
they're useless so we have the answers
now it's just time to implement them and
fight for them and be unapologetic on
that front and if you do that the
republicans will be in a permanent
minority from now until the end of time
when problems are simple
so are the solutions this is why people
like jank uber think that fighting
is all we're lacking if only the right
people said the right combination of
words in front of the right audience
the progressive agenda would be realized
they think that something is easy
because they operate on the outside and
they don't actually know what they're
talking about
consider what kyle kalinski said in
response to david pakman so if bernie
sanders is in the white house
then what bernie sanders goes and gives
in response to me
and he says from the oval office my
friends
we are faced with an obstructionist
congress that's bought off by the
for-profit health insurance companies
and by big farms how does this relate to
anything i said i don't even know what's
going on
i'm kind of over it all right so i guess
there's a 21-minute video that's three
months old that i missed but
i think i'm tapping out uh interesting i
mean you know what you have to
understand is i get google alerts
like 10 times a day of videos like that
and i just can't you know it's
impossible to keep up with
with all of them unfortunate as much as
i would love to obviously
um okay we're standing by for jen
saki oh i do have one more unban request
a user named labanti tech
created their account today
they showed up in my stream they tried
to
paste one two three four five links in a
row all of which were
blocked by twitch they then said f you
david pakman
they then said f you david pakman f you
david pakman few david pacman
they were banned and their unban
request is three more
youtube links so just out of curiosity i
won't put this up on screen i'm gonna
see what they're linking me to
um a video of my own logo that's weird
i'm gonna just have to deny this all
right
that one is denied just a perma-ban i
actually think this person that
that it's ban evasion and that that
individual has already
evaded bans before
like that that username i believe is a
ban of asian
if i'm being clear okay so that's that
i want to say thank you to alvin
yakitori alvin just signed up at
joinpakman.com
using the coupon code immoral 21 if you
can imagine that
which is wild
super chat's coming in white death wants
to know
do i think there's a disconnect between
western progressives and those in the
developing world
does the leninist left contribute to
this i don't i think
i i'm not able to um answer that because
i'd need to know what disconnect you
believe there is
i mean i think there's the assumption
that
so-called western progressives are less
progressive
than in some other places i reject the
idea that the leninist
left is actually progressive i believe
they are
really authoritarian fundamentally
but i need a little more a little more
detail
mini painting studio has a gardening
question do i have pest issues having
trouble with grasshoppers in okc
yeah i don't know anything about that i
do have issues but i certainly don't
know how to solve them
uh honestly when i have a gardening
issue you know who i go to
i go to kevin from epic gardening we are
mutual fans of our respective channels
and his channel crushes mine i'm not
even pretending to be in the same
league as epic gardening but like i
recently had an
issue with my mint and i sent a message
to kevin and that's that's who i'm going
to i would check out his channel
fool in the rain says david you skipped
my super chat
fool in the rain suggestion put a time
stamp on interviews on youtube
of where you left off on the podcast
that's not that's a nice idea all right
we'll look into that
that's not bad what else do we have
ferret queen says wedding planning
stress and our cars got broken into and
robbed
saturday oh no i don't drink so we're
scheduling an appointment at a farm that
for twenty dollars they let you play
with their baby goats that seems nice
from a mental health standpoint that
sounds good
i'm really sorry to hear that though i
mean that that sounds really bad
um what else
oh oh yeah yeah yeah i covered this on
the broadcast show today
but you might find this interesting hold
on a second what's going on
um fox news did a segment basically
saying
it's joe biden's economy might be too
good
this is what they're now going with the
economy is booming
joe biden might be behaving dangerously
these people are unbelievable look at
this
we are seeing a booming american economy
whether it's the jobs market the the dow
as you see on your screen there
continues to hit record highs
you've got wages moving higher so why
is it that this administration wants to
spend all this money when it seems
things are getting better
oh that is just something else um
we have to really worry about joe biden
as a president here
the economy's booming jobs are coming
back
wages are up a real estate is doing well
this the the it's so hot
and yet joe biden is still doing stuff
is the economy getting
dangerously good under democrat
socialist
joe biden here's mike braun's reaction
well that's a good question because
really good questions real consequences
will be felt probably post
2022 and they're calculating all this
expertly in my mind politically we are
seeing a
these people are unbelievable it is um
it must be bad what's going on must be
bad
uh even if it's booming clearly someone
in the democratic party is doing
something wrong this is the worst time
to do anything
that's the uh i love that the headline
is joe biden making the economy too good
um the latest incisive commentary
from fox news as you can uh as you can
very clearly imagine
there um gesh make says you
skipped my super chat all right let's
see
oh sorry with every vaccine including
prescriptions there are always people
who experience symptoms not mentioned in
the literature carlson and others are
doing nothing but continuing the
misinformation
shameful well absolutely one hundred
percent
you are completely right gesh make
patrick says your channel does have more
subscribers than epic gardening oh is
that right that's interesting let's see
epic gardening youtube
let's see what's going on over on epic
gardening
this is like people ask me what i watch
people like oh did you see the latest
jimmy dore video
or tool cheese recent statements and
it's like no i didn't
because i tend to watch stuff like this
let's see
oh i'm growing peas right now in my
garden let's see what tips we have here
today we're going to learn how to grow a
classic spring crop and that would be
peas i've got these from epic gardening
where we're growing
greener thumbs let's go peas are a
quintessential
spring crop one of the easiest and most
tasty and pleasurable things
i can still probably screw it up but i'm
trying right now
grow in spring so in today's video i'm
gonna go through
the major categories of peas because
there are a couple different types that
you want to consider
so you know i feel like i'm i'm thinking
back to the uh
you i don't know if you guys saw the
debate
between stephen kenneth destiny
bennell ii and my former economics
professor richard wolff
where the entire interview was mostly
them
defining things that are not socialism
and things that are not capitalism i
feel like to
frame this video properly kevin should
really
give us a list of a hundred or so
vegetables that are not peas because
otherwise i wouldn't even know
how to interpret this video it's like
okay you're talking about peas but
give me the list of things that are not
peas so we all have like a good
framework from which to start okay let's
continue some sewing and planting
recommendations of course some care and
trellising
and at the end of the video i will show
you my favorite way to eat peas
spoiler alert it really doesn't have
anything to do with going in the kitchen
so cultivate that like button
and i will bless you with 55
more people wow you would have had this
season and let's get into the video
i need some graphics like the oldest
cultivated crops
in the world and they're a staple in
many areas of the world
including here i mean all right let's
get to the growing hold on here we go
plastic i know a lot of my british
gardeners
ladies and gentlemen i want to get to
the transplant
what's nice about peas is that they can
tolerate cold even light
here we go so if you do opt to start
your seeds indoors for
spacing or timing reasons then you just
pop them out and transplant them in and
you're
totally good to go but if you're like
many gardeners including myself
you may just want to make your life a
little bit easier take your pea seeds
and then just direct sow them
in the bed that's what we did right here
on this little trellis
and as far as spacing goes you actually
can be quite aggressive with this
you can put i mean i think we put
somewhere around 40.
they came to me they said sir plant us
closer together just right here
so you can plant them anywhere from one
to three inches apart you could plant
them right next to each other you could
have more than one pea plant
coming out of the same hole as long as
you don't go absolutely overkill they're
quite forgiving
because you got to think about it
they're actually putting a lot of their
growth anyway i don't expect
i have like one pea plant you know this
looks like it that's got to be a bunch
of seeds
but anyway this is like if you're
wondering what i'm doing at 9 p.m at
night it's watching videos like that
uh okay good um
let's see what else we have here even
some peas are not true
peas yes there's a lot of counterfeit
vegetables
hey david really enjoy your channel was
wondering what's your dog's name and do
you know what breed he is
i don't have a dog i don't know i don't
know what you're talking about
um but yeah i don't i don't have a dog
you can react to steven michael davis's
video on corporate agenda no i'm good
i'm good
all we are saying is give peace a chance
fox news the economy is good enough no
need to further improve the country
whatsoever
okay jamal says hey homie is it fair to
use india
in a debate as an example to what the
u.s would be like if we actually
followed
trump's anti-coveted mass backs people
ideas
is it a false equivalency and if so why
yeah it's not a perfect i mean
india's population is like four four
times bigger than the united states
and um uh
there's a different level of
infrastructure different level of income
i mean
i don't think it's a very good analogy
but certainly we could say that
if governors didn't take covet more
seriously
it would have been um absolutely
terrible
even worse than it than it has been have
you read much on the pending financial
crisis related to commercial
mortgage-backed securities ryan grimm on
the intercept has a good piece on it
i haven't my my tell me chat if i'm
right about this my instinct would be
that because of kovid there are
a lot of people abandoning their leases
and this would make people in the
business of subleasing
uh it would put them in a very dangerous
and precarious situation
in the sense that they may have a
20-year lease somewhere and
all of their sub-tenants or many of
their sub-tenants are bailing because of
work from home
and that there are loans out commercial
mortgage loans
that um are on properties increasingly
work
worth less as people are working from
home that that's that would be like my
guess
nobody knows okay all right very good
big thank you to nug wrangler
for 20 months subscribed
with twitch prime also thank you to
andre bavaria geoventure
j tandaway
as well as uh oh no that's it okay four
putting us at 30. um
from what i've read 90 of amazon prime
members never gift their free twitch
membership to anybody
that is a tragic number tragic tragic
number
thoughts on predictions on how hannity's
conversation with caitlyn jenner will go
no but i am very interested in seeing
that i think i might have seen
something about let me see here hannity
jenner i thought i saw a preview of that
let me see here
um
oh maybe not does anybody know when that
is
caitlyn jenner interview
let's see here i am fascinated by it
caitlyn jenner's sit down with hannity
will be live event in malibu fox host
hannity heading to malibu this week
for caitlyn jenner's first tv appearance
she will run in the california recall
sources say hannity's event will be a
town hall style before a live audience
oh i would cover that live that seems
compelling
it doesn't say when it is though
if anybody can find out when that's
going to be
email me i would absolutely love to
cover that
that seems like it would be fascinating
abso whoa
uh looks like we're about to start here
that would be an absolutely fascinating
thing to cover
thanks to the judge as well as s x
score only one me
for signing up via twitch 31 32 and 33.
is that like a is someone reporting live
from the press briefing room is that
what's going on
like actually caitlyn collins from cnn
hanging from gallows has just signed up
via twitch i appreciate that
the coupon code's working fine i see a
lot of people adamant that the coupon
code is not working the code is working
and in fact um alvin yakitori just used
it
signed up with the coupon code immoral
21. if you're wondering what's going on
we're standing by for a white house
press briefing with jensaki
i believe we're just moments away
yeah just white house press briefing if
yes if anyone knows
when the hannity caitlyn jenner live
event will be let me know because i
would be interested in covering that
i think i mean it's going to be
interesting to see republicans have to
balance
being anti-trans which with really not
liking gavin newsom
hey david haven't seen you do any
coverage on u.s solutions summit coming
up may 22nd
i've never heard of it huge names will
be there
cover it u.s solutions summit okay i'll
look into it i don't know what it is
let's see yeah it's like
u.s solutions summit
um i don't recognize any of these names
jimmy dore's wife is a panelist that's
the one name i recognize
yeah i don't think that's for me
that's not looking like something that
would be for me but
this is not necessarily that type of
show
um wednesday six pacific
will be the hannity caitlyn jenner oh
did it say that
oh here oh sorry yeah here it is event
will be broadcast at 6 pacific
i would try i would maybe stream that
tomorrow night everyone
hello okay here we go
[Music]
it's been a while i feel like somebody
taller than me may have been in here
more recently
see uh well happy uh
what day is today tuesday happy tuesday
to all of you we haven't been in here
since last tuesday
so just a couple of items for all of you
at the top uh
i wanted to provide a brief update on
the situation at our southern border
after four years of an immigration
system rooted in destructive and chaotic
policies
numbers looking better is taking the
challenge head-on and is building a
fair orderly and humane immigration
system that's our objective
after coming into office our
administration immediately jumped into
action
to address the influx of migrants at the
border something that began
during and was exacerbated by the trump
administration
and wanted to provide a couple of data
pieces of data you may have seen but
they've come out since the last time we
had a briefing in here
at the end of march there were more than
5 000 children in customs and border
protection
patrol stations today that number is
approximately
600. the amount of time children spend
in cbp facilities is down by 75 percent
from 131 hours at the end of march to
under
30 hours now and just yesterday the
department of homeland security
announced that it will begin the process
of reuniting a number of families
who were separated by the policies of
the previous administration
clearly we're not done there's a lot of
work ahead migration is a dynamic and
evolving challenge but the president has
a plan
and we're working on implementing it
just a few more brief updates for you
as you know friday is jobs day here we
are again and to mark the occasion i
wanted to convey to all of you that we
are
going to be welcoming in treasury
secretary janet yellen to the briefing
room on friday interesting
i would cover that and throughout this
week the president the vice president
cabinet members and other administration
officials are fanning out across the
country to make a forceful argument for
the president's economic
vision president of course began that
push just yesterday
in virginia to talk about the jobs plan
and the family's plan
and it will continue today with the vice
president who will be traveling to will
be in milwaukee
as part of this we'll also have
secretary vilsack joining us in the
briefing room tomorrow
nutrition proposals in the american
families plan
um finally today jeff science and
members of our coveted response team
held their weekly meeting with our
nation's governors this week over 29
million doses
will go out across all of our channels
with two-thirds of those doses
going to jurisdictions and one-third to
federal channels
jeff reiterated the federal government's
commitments to help expand access to the
vaccine boost vaccine confidence and
help states with the unique needs their
unique needs in this vaccination effort
see let me kick us off
thanks again um the president's coded
speech this afternoon you have a
preview of that noise to say what should
the american public expect to hear from
him
um and any new updates of the white
house policies regarding
uh mass wearing or uh or testing
uh here on campus now that cdc's uh have
adjusted their
their guideline last week for fully
vaccinated americans sure
well in terms of the president's remarks
later this afternoon i've been doing
this long enough not to get too far
ahead of him
but i know there's been some reporting
out there so
you all and the american people can
expect to hear an update from the
president on
our goals for vaccinating americans by
middle of this summer also some more
updates on our plans to make the vaccine
more available and accessible
across the country and certainly uh some
information about what people can expect
uh once they get vaccinated nice and in
terms of your second question
uh we are working our team here is
working uh
to determine how we will apply the cdc
guidelines that will constantly be
updated as you all know
to our efforts and the work we do here
in the white house now
there wasn't there weren't
recommendations or weren't there wasn't
uh guidance given
on workplace use right so we're really
talking about
wearing a mask outside i think when i
leave the white house i take my mask off
if i'm coming back into the white house
sometimes i put it back on when i'm
taking the walk just to save some time
but in terms of the number of people who
will be
in the building and uh how we will apply
we're still working through that
internally
and jen there are some reports out of
iran over the weekend over the weekend
about the potential deal for
the release of some u.s hostages there i
know the state department has contested
that report but just sort of
as a as a matter of principle is the
president
open to a dollars for hostages deal
uh essentially ransom payments uh to
free prisoners or does he want
does it need to be a part of a broader
path of the iranians
well our policy as a us government has
not changed on ransom
but i will tell you that discussions to
bring home
americans who are held in iran are
something that are raised
that is raised at the highest level
through discussions obviously those are
indirect
those are often indirect discussions or
we have our own channels of course
and they are separate from the nuclear
discussions in vienna
but it is a commitment and a desire by
this administration to certainly bring
those hostages back but reports over the
weekend
that an agreement had been reached to
exchange prisoners uh
was not true as i said we always raised
this issue
but there's no agreement at this time to
on the release of these four americans
one final one um more than a hundred
days in the administration
uh when you're up here at the
administration you announce the
domestic violence extremism you do uh
give an update on sort of where that is
and what will the final
product of that review be sure let me
give you an update on that
uh so as as you noted zeke on uh that we
annette we would uh be
undergoing a domestic violent uh
extremism review
through the nsd through the national
security team
and we announced that during the
president's first week we i can report
that we completed our policy review in
100 days we allotted
for it uh and right now and this review
of course tackled domestic terrorism
from a range of angles and was comprised
of input from various agencies across
government
so the stage we're in now is that we are
taking uh
we're learning taking a look at what
what occurred during that review
lessons that we've learned and ensuring
that the policy responses
that we've been discussing and
developing are the right ones that's
going to take a little bit of time
our ultimate goal from this review has
always been to develop a strategy that
will convey to the american people
an overarching sense of how we'll be
taking on the threat posed by domestic
terrorism something the president has
talked about as one of the greatest
threats
we face i anticipate an update on that
and the policy recommendations will be
weeks uh not months but at this point
that's the stage of the process
go ahead thank you john um just about
secretary clinton's comments yesterday
about russia the g7 he said that
the united states wants a more stable
and predictable relationship with russia
um secretary blinken just to make sure
okay i think you said secretary clinton
or that's what i heard but
okay and uh and i was um i was wondering
what does russia really have to do to
make that happen
considering the navalny situation
considering the russian
aggression of the ukrainian border how
do you have a stable and predictable
relationship
well our relationship with russia
includes
us voicing concerns where we have them
taking actions and putting consequences
in place when actions warrant as we have
in uh in the treatment of alexey novolny
as we did in reaction to the engagement
or the hacking of our own
election here in the united states at
the same time
we do think there are areas where we can
continue to work together on this is
how historically national security
relationships and diplomatic
relationships
have worked around the world so i think
what we are sending a message of is that
we are not looking to escalate the
relationship uh in
in terms of rhetoric or actions uh we
are of course we reserve the right to
put in place consequences should their
actions warrant
and we want to have a stable
relationship where we will work together
in areas where it is constructive as it
as
might as there might be an opportunity
as it relates to the iran negotiations
as an example
and we will continue to voice concerns
as we have them
and one on um sharing ip data
um because the administration seems to
be over
increasing pressure to share ip data uh
from doctors and even some global
leaders
dr fauci recently uh joined industry
uh during a television interview to say
that that is perhaps not the best way to
get shots and arms
and i was just wondering what the
official white house view is on that
i i wouldn't say that's an exact
character characterization of his uh
comments or remarks that he made but i
will say that
i would expect we'll have something to
say about this once the wto
session gets underway obviously
ambassador tai
is would be making a recommendation to
the president that's not something that
has
happened at this point and obviously
just for people to understand for
everyone to understand this process
because sometimes it's short handed in a
on television or in other places what
we're talking about is the united states
position
it's a wto process and what ultimately
happens here will not be
up to the united states alone this is a
waiver that there would have to be
agreement
among wto members on i think what i saw
dr fauci's comments speak to as well
which is certainly our position is that
our objective is to save lives by
producing as much supply as possible
and getting shots and arms around the
world in the most effective way
and we're determining what the right
steps are to do exactly that okay thank
you and
one last one on india i know i've been
asking you constantly
obviously really important is the
administration doing all it can
to help india well let me give you an
update and i know we've provided a few
of those but i don't think we've done a
substantive one here on what has
happened
or or what the recent shipments have
been so six
air shipments funded by usaid have
departed the united states
five of which have already arrived in
india these flights include health
supplies oxygen oxygen supplies
n95 masks rapid diagnostic tests
and medicine and these are a lot of the
components that the indian government
has expressed a
vital need for more flights are on the
way with total assistance expected to
exceed 100 million
dollars at the request of the government
of india usaid provided these urgently
needed supplies to the indian
red cross to ensure they reach those
most in need as quickly as possible
in terms of oxygen support which as you
all know is a big component of what they
need right now
we're talking about oxygen cylinders so
usaid delivered approximately 1500
cylinders
that will remain in india and can
repeatedly be refilled
at local supply centers with more plane
loads to come
oxygen concentrators usaid has sent
approximately 550 oxygen concentrators
to obtain
oxygen from ambient air and usaid has
also delivered a large-scale unit to
support up to 20
patients each of an oxygen generation
unit
we've also sent 2.5 million and 95 masks
and we have an additional
12.5 million and 95 masks available
should that request come from the indian
government
and we've directed our own order of
astrazeneca manufacturing supplies to
india
allowing india to make over 20 million
doses we've also provided 1 million
rapid diagnostic tests
and this weekend this past weekend usaid
delivered
twenty thousand treatment courses of the
anti-viral doug remsevier to help treat
hospitalized patients
and we're also working one of the
questions that's come up is about
assistance and know-how and
cdc experts will work in close
coordination with india's public health
experts
in uh in the following areas laboratory
surveillance and epidemio epidemiology
i'm not a medical expert
emergency response and operations
development uh bioinformatics for
genomic sequencing some risky reading
there so we are in close touch that's a
summary of what we've done just over the
last several days and we're working to
meet the immediate needs they have now
even as we consider
uh you know when we have astrozenica
doses available what can happen there
okay go ahead thank you uh you mentioned
secretary ellen is coming on friday she
said in remarks published today that it
may be that
interest rates will have to rise
somewhat to make sure that our economy
doesn't overheat does president biden
agree with it i think
president certainly agrees with his
treasury secretary but i will say that
one of the reasons i think you're asking
this question is about inflation
concerns and something that we
uh watch closely here obviously in the
treasury department
and in the white house in close
coordination
uh and that is something where uh
there's agreement i looked at secretary
yellen's remarks or the ones that i saw
which he also conveyed is how vital it
is to make these investments now and how
important it is for our economy
for investment in research and
development for
uh leveling the playoff playing field on
the workforce to make exactly this
investment so
of course uh officials who don't work
here in the federal reserve and other
places
closely watch what needs to happen i'm
not going to speak on interest rates
but we also take inflationary risk
incredibly seriously
and our economic experts have
conveyed that they think this would be
temporary and that the
benefits far outweigh the concern part
because of course the previous
administration was routinely criticized
for
repeatedly sharing its views on what
rates should do
secretary ellen is expressing her view
on what will happen to rates do you
think that this is
an appropriate comment for treasury
secretary penny is she expressing an
opinion
on what the fed should do when she says
this well i would say of all people
secretary yellen certainly understands
the independence and the role of federal
reserve
and i think she was simply answering a
question and conveying how we balance
decision making here one other thing
this week facebook is going to decide
whether or not to
reinstate donald trump's accounts on
facebook and instagram yeah tomorrow if
he is reinstated
is there any change in strategy that the
white house would put in messaging in
other words if he's on these platforms
does that change what you do at all no
go ahead thank you jen ahead of the
president's speech today
is there any context or data you can
share
about the holdouts about people who are
still not getting vaccinated or signing
up to get vaccinated
so we can understand if the problem is
access to the vaccine
or hesitancy not access unsafe
sure well first let me say that what
we've seen is that the more people who
are vaccinated and
today he'll talk about the fact but you
are aware of this data that
150 million people in this country now
have had one dose adults i should say
someone should really ask is the economy
getting too
good and is that dangerous that
confidence increases and the more people
want to get vaccinated that's not a
surprise to us that was what we
anticipated and hoped for
given if your friend or your neighbor or
somebody in your community is vaccinated
it gives you greater confidence about
the efficacy of the vaccine and maybe
you see what the impact and the benefits
are
we always expected we should to be at
this phase where
once we reached that percentage
approximately of
people who were vaccinated once we got
to the point where
it was no longer an issue of access to
supply because we have more than enough
supply for
the american public that it would become
more and more difficult to
meet people where they are and to reach
them and the biggest factor we've seen
consistently
uh has we always focus on confidence of
course but even with confidence the
biggest challenge is access
and access can mean a lot of things it
can mean
concern about safety though we've seen
improvements in confidence levels
it can also mean where do you get a
vaccine which is why we've invested so
heavily and the president will talk
about this today
in programs like our pharmacy program
mobile vaccine units mass vaccination
sites partnering with primary fair
care physicians local doctors et cetera
but also why we announced made the
announcement last week about paid leave
so that people can take a day off of
work and they don't have to worry about
losing income we were seeing that as a
factor
so we're constantly evaluating how to
make this easier and more acceptable
accessible but we we knew we'd be at
this point where it would become
more difficult and we've been preparing
for that thank you
and i know you've seen the reports about
the fda
um approving the pfizer vaccine for
kids between the ages of 12 and 15. not
yet
not yet but is there anything you can
tell us about how close they might be
and
in the meantime what the administration
is doing to prepare
so that those kids can get better great
questions sure well i can't get ahead of
the fda process and
certainly in part because we want to
ensure people have confidence in the
safety of vaccines when they make a
decision
but i will say the president will talk a
bit about what preparations we are
making here
to ensure that if a vaccine is approved
if the fires or vaccine is approved by
the fda or others in the future
uh that we make that accessible to uh
additional
uh younger populations
on sunday ron claims said that the white
house had invited a group of republican
senators to come talk about
infrastructure
do you have any details about that
meeting including whether the president
will attend
sure so i think he was referring to the
invitation the president made to senator
capito that we announced
last week and and a group of members
she selects to come to the white house
since
congress is on senate is on recess this
week we anticipate that meeting
being next week and it just hasn't been
locked in yet on the day
and who will be included in that group
of attendees
but that's what he was referring to this
weekend but we don't have an update
quite yet as we have one we'll we'll
share that with all of you thank you
good person thanks jen i just want to
give you a chance to respond to the
accusations that the
american federation of teachers the
country's largest
second largest teachers union influenced
the cdc's guidelines on reopening
schools yet
republican senator tom cotton saying
that this is evidence of a politicized
public health agency
answering at the beckham called the
teachers union so how does the white
house respond
well i would say first that's false
let's take a step back and talk about
how the cdc works the cdc it's actually
long-standing best practice
for the cdc to engage with organizations
and groups that are going to be impacted
by guidance and recommendations issued
by the agency it doesn't mean they are
taking everything they want or even a
percentage of what they want but it's
important to understand the
implementation components they do so to
ensure
that recommendations are feasible and
that they adequately
address the safety and well-being of the
individuals the guidance is aimed to
protect
protect so the cdc engaged with around
50 stakeholders that are on the front
lines in this pandemic
and have requisite perspective for the
guidance
the president reiterated last week that
july 4th is the target date
for returning american life to something
closer the leaf blowers back can you
just
define what exactly closer to normal
is what does that look like for the
average american
well uh first the president will have
more about his uh updated
goals that we have as an administration
uh by that july
timeline that he'll talk about later
this afternoon uh you know what he's
talked about is
if you're giving incentives for people
to be vaccinated to understand what the
benefits are what the benefits are of
getting a shot or two shots
and one of the things he's talked about
for some time since his prime time
address before the joint address was
people being able to gather in their
backyard and have a barbecue uh
and obviously we follow the advice and
guidelines of our health and medical
experts but if we increase
yeah i think we've figured out where
most of my callers call from clearly the
the lawn where those leaf blowers are
going more things that they're used to
so the guidance last week of course said
that if you're vaccinated
uh you don't have to wear a mask outside
as long as you're not in a crowd
it also said if you're vaccinated you
can go a lot of places
if you're wearing a mask and you can
feel safe and comfortable but he'll have
more to say later this afternoon about
the july timeline
okay one more question about since we've
been talking a lot about the refugee cap
something that's
not entirely uh similar but certainly
related the afghan special immigrant
visa program is facing
this backlog of thousands and thousands
of applicants and of course
time is running out with the withdrawal
beginning over the weekend so
can you just kind of summarize what
exactly is the plan to
address this backlog before all u.s
troops withdrawal
you know kristin it's a great question
it's an important program the president
talked about of course has talked about
in the past and he is committed to
i would say the state department would
oversee uh the process for those visas
so i would point you to them is there a
planner is the plan still being
drafted uh i don't have an update on the
plan i will just convey to you that
there's a plan
ensuring that people who have been
partners to the united states who have
played such a vital role
uh who are eligible can apply and that
we do that our embassy
of course is is remaining there and a
presence there as well
but they would be the right agency to
talk about processing and timeline and
what that looks like
you guys might surge volunteers or staff
to the embassy in kabul to help
it's a great question but i would again
point you to the state department
because the personnel would come from
there
go ahead hello rpg captains it is now
going to be set at 62
500 this fiscal year but president biden
says he doesn't think we'll actually get
there so
where does he think will be by september
30th on the number of refugees
well i i would say first that um you
know what's important about this cap
is one that he wanted to as he said in
his statement yesterday he wanted to
eliminate any lingering doubt
from any refugee across the world that
the united states wasn't a country that
would welcome
refugees in to apply under the biden
harris administration that's exactly who
we want to be
but setting this cap the objective is
twofold one
is it um helps uh send a message that
message to the world i just conveyed
but also it helps get the muscles
working that have atrophied over the
last several years when we were not
welcoming in
many many refugees so this is not just a
federal government or u.s government
a you know effort there are so many
organizations who play incredible roles
in the united states and around the
world they have been understaffed
they've been under-resourced
and some of our success will depend on
the ability to rebuild those systems
so uh yes we will not it is unlikely we
will meet that 62
500 cap it is actually historically
rarely is that the ca are the caps meant
or met i should say but our objective is
to get those muscles working
again and send a clear message to the
world right now the number is still
around 2000 that was the latest we had
gotten so it just was
is there an update on what that number
is right now i can see if there's an
updated number we have had people start
coming in
uh because we resumed the flights and
because we
uh overturned the policy that prevented
refugees from applying from the middle
east and from
africa uh we're constantly updating
those numbers but i'll see if there's a
number to update you on
and then on what jeff zions told the
governors today on that call that now
the white house will redistribute
vaccine allocations if the state doesn't
order the full allocation they get that
week
can you just walk us through what
changed in that policy since
last month when the michigan governor
made a direct appeal to the president to
get more vaccines for her state
she was told that couldn't happen at the
time so can you just walk us through the
thinking
sure this policy change sure well first
we are always evaluating how to ensure
we're getting
more supply out to the country and out
to
the american people more shots and arms
so even just a few weeks ago we were in
a different phase of our vaccination
effort when supply was more constrained
and states
for the most part were ordering at or
near their full
allocation so what this announcement
does and what
what jeff conveyed to the governors is
they can still order it's up to them
they can order up to their full
allocation based on population
they can also order less than their full
allocation
and the less the the doses that are not
then given to that state will then go
into
uh kind of an overarching supply that
could then be distributed to other
states by population
now that same governor could the
following week decide to
order back to their maximum allocation
so it gives flexibility week by week
but it's really just an indication that
we're in a different phase now that we
were than we were even a couple of weeks
ago in terms of access to supply and we
want to ensure
the doses are uh that we free up on
ordered unused uh
and unordered doses and last question
does the president still think that we
will get to hurt immunity in the u.s
this calendar year well the president's
uh
we we try to leave the predictions of uh
when we will reach
uh any definition by medical and health
experts of that term
i will say that what the president will
talk about today
is what percentage of the population he
hopes
to be vaccinated by this summer that
obviously is a step forward and what we
can do from an
operational standpoint from the white
house from jeff science and
arkova team is continue to
operationalize getting these shots out
into the country but assessments of
what that will mean um we will leave to
our health and medical experts and apply
our guidance accordingly
jen to follow up on that question then
from caitlin the president was asked
about that yesterday
and said there's a debate about it and
on the call with the governors today we
obtained audio of it dr fauci seemed to
downplay the notion of hurt immunity
he called it an elusive concept of a
number so
is that no longer the administration's
goal does the white house not believe
that's possible
is this a deliberate shift away from
that
again it's a great question i just don't
want to answer and i know we typically
have
a um briefing with our health and
medical team on tuesdays so
you may have to wait for the next one or
the next time one of these doctors is on
television to talk about the definition
of it uh
but what our objective is is of course
to vaccinate
as much of the population as quickly as
we can
and the definition of what that will
mean yeah this is all like you know
she's not going to say what herd
immunity threshold would be and
and if and when it it's here's how many
vaccines we've got we know there is
hesitancy
we are working on that we should get
vaccinated because other countries that
have done it have seen cases go
almost down to statistically nothing
planning to phase out
fema's mass vaccine sites in favor of
focusing more on
local level community health centers the
mobile centers that we've been talking
about
is it not effective to be using those
mass vaccine sites anymore at this point
in the campaign
it's more effective in some places than
others so we announced a couple new mass
vaccination sites
last thursday or friday uh there are
some places where
those max vaccination sites that's a
mouthful for some reason
have not stayed open and we evaluate
working in uh coordination with of
course governors
local health and medical experts on
what's working we look at the data and
see what's working
and there are some programs like our
pharmacy program we initially
launched it as a pilot with just a
couple thousand pharmacies right now
it's over 40
000 or even greater than that because
that we've seen is very effective
we're partnering with local primary care
physicians
in part because through our data we see
that uh
people trust their local doctors and
that if it's easy if you know you're
going there to get your checkup that
that is an easy place to
do vaccinations so there are certain
parts of the country or certain
communities where we still have
mass vaccination sites we'll continue to
open them but we're constantly
evaluating
the best delivery mechanisms and if
something is not the most effective one
we will make changes
uh go ahead thank you does the
administration want or does it already
have some plans
being uh formulated to allow in foreign
visitors this summer
in the same way the eu has pretty
clearly said that's it we're gonna open
the doors
uh they have um but we uh again this is
a case which i know is
endlessly frustrating to people and i
will acknowledge that uh where we will
uh rely on the uh advice and the
recommendations by our health and
medical experts on
uh what is getting dangerously close to
booking some tickets i want to hear that
europe guidance soon ahead of their
process
and what i anticipate in terms of any
changes to travel restrictions
okay thank you and another one um
against the background of fighting which
is going on now in helmand in
afghanistan
after the u.s troops left the taliban
and government forces uh
started in um what is what is what is
going to be the president's message
if this specter of a taliban takeover
which is obviously
quite possible happens after september
what's going to be his message to the
afghan people including the many who
probably don't support the taliban is it
going to be essentially
look we're sorry this is now your affair
we're out of here i mean
is there going to be anything more than
that that he can say
to them well i will say that when the
president gave his speech
on our decision to pull troops out of
afghanistan
he talked about the fact that we will
continuing we will continue of course to
have an over the horizon
presence that we will continue to
provide a range of humanitarian
and other direct assistance we will
still have an embassy
at this point in afghanistan and a
presence there at a diplomatic
level so what the announcement we made
was about removing troops
because it is in the best interest of
our own national security but
he believes in diplomacy believes that
is the right path forward
and we'll we will continue to support
that and work with our international
partners around the world to move
forward
could he foresee a day when when the us
and the u.s embassy
and the united states deals with the
taliban government which is
ruling afghanistan obviously we watch
closely and work
closely with our partners in the region
on what the future looks like but i'm
not going to get ahead of the status in
afghanistan
uh go ahead yeah a couple questions uh
the white house
said the president wants to see progress
on the american jobs plan
by the end of this month and passage by
the summer does that same time
frame apply to the family's plan that he
released last week
that's a great question i mean we
obviously just introduced it it's
introduced it some period of time after
we introduced the american jobs plan i
expect we'll have
discussions with members of congress
about components of each
different members have uh support or
more excited about different components
of different parts of
the plan uh but i don't have a new
timeline to set for the american
family's plan well with those
uh negotiations and the meeting that you
referenced
coming up with republican senators uh
you mentioned we'll talk infrastructure
is he also going to talk
the family's plan with those senators uh
uh
when he holds that meeting well this
particular meeting i mean there's
there's dozens and dozens of meeting
engagements phone calls conversations
that are happening
on a regular basis and a couple of um
you know
secretary pete uh buddha judge is going
to be briefing the congressional
progressive caucus this week on the
package as well as speaking
at leader hoyer's committee chair weekly
brief meeting our jobs cabinet continues
to make one-on-one calls to members on
both sides of the aisle
and some of them are also in districts
this week amplifying with members
our legislative affairs team is doing
briefings and having dozens of calls and
engagements
as well this one particular meeting
is related to a counter proposal that
senator capito
made which is focused on the american
jobs plan
so i would expect that to be a primary
focus of the meeting
but there will be a range of meetings
about uh the proposals the american
families plan
as well and different proposals that the
president has put on the table
at this point uh when you think about
getting these plans passed through
congress
are you envisioning both plans being
combined into one bill i mean is that
what the white house favors or
separately what's the position right now
we're open to a range of mechanisms for
the president's ideas moving forward but
exactly what you're talking about is
part of the discussion we're going to
have with members of congress and
there's an openness to
smaller package to different components
moving forward together
we will leave those mechanics to leaders
in congress
but what we're discussing with them is
where we can find agreements on many of
the proposals and ideas the president
has put forward
a question on the family's plan during
the campaign president
uh biden proposed free tuition
four-year colleges and universities for
students whose families
earn 125 000 or less his family's plan
released last week as you know
only offers free tuition to students to
attend two-year
community colleges why did he not go
through uh with that larger plan for
free
schooling at universities in college and
why was it limited to just fair question
community colleges
well let me first say uh well the
american families plan as a historic
investment
in education and child care uh free
universal pre-k uh for uh for three and
four-year-olds across the country which
we know would have a huge impact 50
you're 58 more likely to graduate from
high school if you go to preschool as
opposed to daycare
and two years of community college but
this is not the totality of what the
president hopes to do on education
uh this is a a significant investment a
historic investment that he's proposing
but
we're less than i know 100 less than 107
days i know we are into the
administration go ahead
thanks ben um the president white house
of education
believes that public schools should
require that students
get vaccinated um once folks under 16 is
available to get vaccinated whether it's
visa and
what have you in the next couple of
months uh i i don't
uh it's not my understanding that we're
putting in new requirements
here from the federal government i would
expect the department of education will
work with local schools and school
districts on
implementation and how to keep students
and the federal government's not going
to require that today
has come out in support of teachers
unions who are already pretty public
about the fact that they
want students under 16 to get vaccinated
if they can get vaccinated and are
eligible to get vaccinated
i don't have any anticipation of
requirements from the federal government
at this point in time but obviously if
we'll look to our health and medical
experts on any additional guidance to
provide
but even my passing support on social
media i know the president is very
pro-union
we just have to keep your duty all the
time would at least invite them here to
have conversations so do you anticipate
that
president biden would at least come out
on the side of the union for this
specific issue
i wouldn't i would say that the
president is going to abide by the
advice and guidance of health and
medical experts
and certainly we put out public health
information and we've put out mitigation
steps that schools can take
in order to protect their school
population
uh but i don't have anything else to
predict for you at this point in time
okay just one more sure i just want to
get the house opportunity to respond to
the backlash liz cheney has been getting
recently for coming out and saying that
you know obviously fighting won the
election fair and square and by the
republicans are saying that that's not
true it's a bit of hogwash and
um obviously taking my own white house
has no comment on this chain
is the website response to the
republicans kind of ganging up on her or
having a negative reaction to that
well i would say first that um you know
the republican party seems to be
spending a lot of blood sweat and tears
trying to figure out
where they stand and what they stand for
and
that's their prerogative but our focus
is on
and how we're spending our time is on
defeating the pandemic growing our
economy
building on that for the long run and
it's no secret that the president
doesn't see eye to eye on many policies
with uh congresswoman cheney but
his view is that the american people
elected him and
also many people representing congress
representing them in congress to
solve problems for them and uh he's
going to continue to seek civility even
when he disagrees uh go oh let me go
let me just get around and then i'll
come back to you if that's okay go ahead
jonathan okay
thanks uh president biden's recently
named up
nominated somebody to run the federal
motor carrier safety administration
first would be his first senate
confirmed administrator in years
the agency has been criticized for years
by trace
for traffic safety advocates for not
doing anything especially if the truck
safety was supposed to regulate
for example since 26. this guy i love
proposed rule
to limit the speed of trucks which
hasn't been acted on now in five years
did the president discuss safety
her to take over the agency
i'm not sure there's been a discussion
with her directly obviously if she was
selected or nominated to serve in this
particular role but
it's my understanding that the
department sometimes i think how funny
it would be if joe biden had like a
completely normal policy
plan but then on something really
specific like the speed of trucks he was
like i believe trucks should be able to
go 90 miles an hour on the highway and
it was like there was no rhyme or reason
as to why that was something biden cared
about and it was completely out of line
these are the things i think of to
myself like how would we react to that
so
truck should go 90. i don't know been
down to one of five board members for
the last year uh why did he make that
some of his early
earliest appointments or nominations
well as you touch on jonathan uh the
the chemical safety board has a
significant backlog of cases pending
uh currently only has one board member
out of five uh the president wanted to
fill the vacancies or hopes to fill the
vacancies
quickly to make sure the board is able
to fulfill its responsibilities
if biden was like i believe regular cars
should have six wheels
uh what all right i don't know this
question is a bunch of lawmakers
including
one i cover who would love to still see
another round of
stimulus checks or direct payments even
every month until the pandemic ends
or is that something that it hasn't been
either the president's new proposals but
that's something that like i guess what
i'm saying is
if there was clearly a better candidate
if it was cl if it was biden versus
trump
and they had all of their same positions
and obviously biden's better
but biden had some completely wacky like
all contact lenses should be bright red
just so you know when someone's wearing
contact lenses would it change our
general perception of the fact that
biden's better than trump kids
under six obviously we're continuing to
evaluate what their needs are
to continue to get the pandemic under
control put people back to work but we
think that's also a proposal that will
have a long-term benefit
there could be another round of direct
payments in one of these bills
we'll see what members of congress
propose but those are not free
uh go ahead in the back john my first
question is on ambassadorships
many key picks
have not been made for these roles which
serve as a representation of american
university
overseas the united states has never had
a lesbian woman or transgender person as
an ambassador
is the president missing an opportunity
to name those firsts
well given we haven't named uh many
ambassadors
quite yet and we hope too soon stay
tuned um
uh certainly the president looks to
ensuring that the people representing
him not just in the united states but
around the world
represent the diversity of the country
and that certainly includes um
people who are lgbtq a member of the
transgender community
i don't know i don't have any
predictions for you on that front um but
i will say that he's uh soon i'm sure
we'll be evaluating some
uh recommended nominees coming from our
personnel office and our
national security team to fill some
important posts um and he
of course always looks at diversity
could you define soon a little bit
further what was that
like days months weeks well i think it
depends on when the president makes some
decisions and
uh he'll continue to consider a range of
options for
a lot of the positions that are out
there and still remain
uh vacant i will say having served the
state department for a couple of years
there are incredible career service
employees who are serving
in these embassies around the world who
are representing the united states and
our values
um that continues to be the case but of
course we're eager to have ambassadors
in place and confirmed
to represent the president and the vice
president
thank you my second inquiry is
on the president's speech to congress
last week
he told transgender youth he has their
backs
and the president made these remarks in
the context of states
enacting laws against transgender youth
including a measure the
technology governor signed just today
requiring parental notification on lgbtq
lgbtq inclusive school curriculum
um the president's inclusion of
transgender people in his speech to
congress
is significant in and of itself but what
will the president having their backs
look like going forward
right well certainly the president has
put in place
has signed executive orders he's also
used the power of the bully pulpit and
his presidency to convey that
transgender rights are human rights and
that is his belief in the view of his
administration and how he expects
policies to be implemented that includes
ensuring ensuring that transgender
youth have the opportunity to play
sports and to be treated
equally in states across the country so
he will look to members of his
administration
to implement what his view is and what
he what his value is as president
would you rule out legal action against
these laws going forward as part of that
i will leave you that to the department
of justice um go ahead in the back
thank you jim very much couple of
questions and then another one from a
colleen
uh will president biden give an update
on sharing vaccines with the worms
today and like for example is there any
consideration
to let go uh the unordered vaccine
supply that will be redistributed here
also to other countries is the
consideration for that
well our focus right now is on allowing
the
um available the astrazeneca vaccine
supply that we have
expected over the next couple of months
going through a process to determine
where we can get provide those vaccines
so right now we have zero doses
available
we hope to have about 10 million in the
coming weeks and about an additional 50
million
in the coming months and there's a
process internally that's determining
where those doses will go but that's
really where our focus is at this moment
but we will continue to evaluate ways to
increase and expand
global vaccine supply around the world
beyond that so does the white house
believe they could be doing more
or faster to help closing the gap
between vaccination
in rich countries and the rest of the
world or
do you believe the 60 million dollar
doses of extrazenica
are enough i don't think i said it was
enough i think i said that that is where
our focus is at this moment
but we will continue to look for ways to
our objective
is to uh be contributing a big
contributing component
of providing as much global supply
in as cost-effective manner as possible
and that's what we're evaluating now
so the 60 million is what we know we
will have available in the coming months
you just went through a list of help
that administration is giving to india
and there is a great coordination to
help angel why are not
we are not seeing the same response or
engagement from this white house
uh with brazil a lot of experts around
the world are saying brazil
is leaving a humanitarian catastrophe
and there are more death in brazil than
in india so why such a difference and we
know that brazil also asked for oxygen
sedatives is the white house or is the
administration considering
sending additional help to brazil well
recognizing that the fight against kova
19 is a global struggle
we are in partner working to partner
with the government of brazil and the
pan american health organization to
finalize access to 20 million dollars
worth of critical
intubation medications needed to save
brazilian
lives these medications will come from
the us government
a facilitated purchase and from the u.s
strategic national stockpile
the support is being offered to offset
global supply shortages and when it will
enable brazil to
receive sufficient medication to meet
their immediate
hospital needs so that is an effort
that's underway has not yet been
finalized but
we are working in partnership with the
government of brazil on that
brazil being the least to receive the
astrazeneca
doses there are a range of requests
we've had from around the world we're
evaluating those needs now
but i can't get ahead of that process
can i just ask one more from my
colleague
mvs radio from mexico uh he's asking
that he's saying that at least 20 people
have been killed in protests
that have been going on in colombia for
a week now
nearly a thousand cases of police
brutality have been reported
is the president being briefed about the
situation in colombia and what is
the white house response i'll have to
ask our national security team
on the latest engagement we've had with
the colombian government and others on
that and i will get back to you with a
comment
quickly one last one sorry uh does the
white house believe the former president
uh president trump should
be allowed to return to facebook
it's a decision made being made by an
independent oversight board um beyond
that we don't have any further comment
go ahead thanks jen i want to ask you a
few about taxes real quick
um fun yeah taxes goes for the last one
in the back right
that's right that's right um on the salt
cap some congressional democrats are
saying
no salt cap repeal no deal with the
president
um as it goes forward with his tax plan
democrats up on the hill
we know the position that the white
house has had for several weeks now so
i'm wondering
what's more likely at this point for the
white house to move towards these
congressional democrats
or do or congressional democrats in this
case to
back off their position eventually we
don't know yet this is democracy in
action
negotiation about this uh we are having
discussions we are certainly aware
of the members who have conveyed a
strong view
about the assault deduction and
we'll have that discussion with them
we're eager to hear their proposals some
of them have put some proposals forward
i think what we're factoring in here in
the discussion is that
i think as you and i have talked about
before this is not a revenue raiser
so it would be additional cost that's
okay
but then you have to determine either
how to pay for it what other things are
cut out
certainly that would be a part of the
discussion you heard from the president
yesterday about the step up in basis he
sort of laid out the argument as to why
that should be eliminated
for wealthy individuals upon inheritance
essentially lowers the capital gains
burden the
tax foundation gave the gave an example
100 million in gains they say
that the tax on that would be 61 percent
we know the white house's position that
the wealthiest need to pay their fair
share i think anyone would agree that
100 million dollars in gains is a lot of
money
but i guess the question is whether or
not a 61 percent tax bill
is reasonable does the white house
believe that's reasonable
i'd have to talk to our number crunchers
about the specific example you gave
i i don't know what percentage of people
have a hundred
million dollars in capital gains maybe
you know that sounds like
quite a lot to me uh but the fundamental
value here the president is conveying is
that uh
his proposals are about and making a
historic investment in education
in child care that's going to make us
more competitive to compete with china
to bring more women back into the
workforce he's proposed a way to pay for
it that's going to impact as it relates
to capital gains
0.3 percent of the population and the
example you gave i don't even know
that's probably 0.00 i don't know what
percentage of the population
that's his proposal there are other
proposals that can be put forward but i
have to look at the specific
statistics to with our team to to give
an evaluation on that
in the americans family american
families plan it calls for financial
banks
and financial institutions yeah a lot of
people have asked me what i'm planning
to do with my
with my gains um if this
if the capital i mean it's i i'm just
i'm not playing i don't even pay
attention because i'm not planning on
selling anything i i just i'm holding
that maybe that's the federal government
having too big of an insight
into what's going into your bank account
and what's coming out of your bank
account
along with that i would just make filing
your taxes a whole lot
tougher it's already a pain it's already
a pain but
is that too much for the federal
government to know what's coming in and
what's coming out of your bank so
what this proposal is as you know but
just to explain to others
is uh cracking down more on ensuring
people are paying the tax
uh the taxes they should be paying on
their income at the rates they should be
paying them at
there's a lot of imp there's a number of
implementation mechanisms for that and
obviously the irs can
outline that more specifically than i
can but again this is a proposal about
how to pay for historic investments in
child care
and education if people have alternative
proposals that don't raise taxes on
people making less than four hundred
thousand dollars a year
that will help pay for this we're quite
open to them
mitch mcconnell um put forth or
basically said that
republicans would be willing to go
forward with the 600 billion dollar
infrastructure plan
no do not touch the corporate tax
structure that is currently in place
the white house's response to that is
what
well i think one there's a counter
proposal that we're happy that we're
going to have a discussion about with
senator capito
next week there's lots of discussions at
a staff level uh
i think the question there is is he
suggesting we don't need to pay for the
proposal
it sounds like it unless there's an
alternative essentially people who use
which which again as we've as we've
talked about user fees
um would put the burden on the backs of
the american people
would in short would make it so that
people driving a car it depends on what
use the user fees are
right if it's the uh get basically a tax
for the number of miles you drive as an
example or other user fees
that means people making fifty thousand
a hundred thousand hundred fifty
thousand dollars a year
are going to have to pay for these
proposals we have a difference of you on
the pay force our view is that
the one percent of people who are making
over uh 400 000
a year can afford to pay a little bit
more but we can have a discussion about
that
thank you thanks everyone
all right many questions and some
answers there
uh another press briefing in the books
um nug wrangler says ronald reagan was
stirring up drama with me and sam cedar
have i looked at it no but if someone
sends it to me i would check it out as
many of you know i don't watch any
political shows
so i never know what's going on but if
someone can email me whatever that's in
reference to info
davidpakman.com i will check it out
tomorrow
at 4 pm eastern i will be playing in a
chess tournament the botez sisters are
organizing
a bullet streamer chess tournament
i will be playing in it that's tomorrow
at 4 pm i will stream my participation
probably will go live about 15 minutes
before that
and then i will think about um
streaming the sean hannity caitlyn
jenner event tomorrow night although i'm
worried that there may be copyright
issues so i'm going to investigate that
so potentially two streams tomorrow
potentially
alright i'll see everybody soon